Each time a cigarette is lit, it emits more than 7,000 kinds of chemicals
It is not surprising that smoking is one of the leading causes of death worldwide
But with an estimated 1.3 billion smokers, what happens when a smoker stops smoking?
Within the first 20 minutes of quitting, the blood pressure and heart rate return to normal
This is due to the fact that the nicotine found in cigarettes released adrenaline and norepinephrine, which raise the heart rate and narrow the blood vessels
These symptoms cause coldness in the limbs but with time the hands and feet return to normal temperature
Because of the body's intense desire for nicotine, dizziness, drowsiness, nervous feelings, and even difficulty sleeping occur
Because nicotine also stimulates the secretion of extra dopamine unusually
These are the physiological responses expected after quitting
Eight hours after quitting smoking, carbon monoxide inhaled by oxygen allows normal flow in the bloodstream, and there is a competition between carbon monoxide and oxygen in the hemoglobin binding in the blood
Which leads to stretching of the circulatory system
Once purified, it gives more oxygen
But for those who have long smoked, exposure to carbon monoxide causes red blood cell hypertrophy, making the blood thick and causing an increase in blood pressure.
Surprisingly, 24 hours after you quit smoking you will increase cough and that is how your body uses the lungs to purify all toxins
At that moment, the incidence of cardiovascular disease is also lower
All in just 24 hours.
After 48 hours, nicotine is removed and its components completely removed from the body
The nerve endings begin to grow again.
Tars, cigarettes and other chemicals reduce the number of taste buds that are heavy with few blood vessels
So start now to regain its sensitivity, which makes the taste of food better than before
But some hard-boiled smokers may no longer have the same taste as they did
During the first 72 hours, the symptoms of nicotine disappearance begin to appear in the form of headaches, nausea, abdominal cramps, as well as psychological symptoms such as anxiety and depression
These symptoms appear as a result of the use of substances that cause addiction, including caffeine
But after that, the worst phase is over
After one month, the risk of type 2 diabetes and cardiovascular disease decreases
During the third to ninth month, the damaged cilia in the lung have been almost completely repaired, with their bristles removing impurities and residues in the lung
This leads to the disappearance of some symptoms, such as coughing and respiratory weakness almost completely.
After about one year, the risk of coronary heart disease as a direct result of arteriosclerosis caused by secretions of fatty substances or scar tissue caused by the deterioration of the arterial wall condition is reduced by about half.
In the first ten years, the proportion of lung cancer in the first ten years becomes less than half of a person who has not quit smoking
Within 15 years, the risk of having a heart attack is reduced to the average of people who never smoked.
No doubt these results are not certain, and the rate of cigarettes you smoke per day
Or in the year plays an important role in the body's ability to heal
Unfortunately, there will be some permanent damage to the lungs, and there will be an increase in susceptibility to various lung diseases
While quitting smoking may be difficult, the benefits far outweigh the disappearance of the initial symptoms
Ultimately, the best way to prevent all this from happening is to avoid smoking from the ground up.
If you need some extra motivation and motivation
Follow our videos that may give you an incentive to quit your habits or focus on other goals you hope to achieve
Ask what is going on in your mind by writing in the comments below the screen or through social media
Subscribe to the channel for more weekly science videos every Thursday